é
hier. Catherine François.
- Cette mission, financée
par l'État, va parcourir
en 18 mois 20 000 km
à travers l'Afrique.
- À partir d'écrits, photos et
autres archives, ce documentaire
suit les traces d'une expédition
menée par l'explorateur
Maurice Griaule et l'écrivain
Michel Leiris, entre Dakar
et Djibouti, de 1931 à 1933.
Une expédition pollllller
à la rencontre des peuples
des pays africains colonisés
par la France, découvrir
leurs cultures et collecter
les objets dons s s se servent.
3600 artefacts seront ainsi
envoyés usususée d'ethnographie
à Paris, qui va devenir
le Musée de l'Homme.
MARC PETITJEAN, réalisateur
"Dakar-Djibouti 1931"
- Ce j j j'ai essayé de faire
dans le film, c'était de
raconter tant que je le pouvais
l'histoire de certains objets,
comme le kono, qui est l'une
s s s pièces maitresses du musée
du quai Branly, qui est un très
bel objet, mais qui a aussi
une charge rituelle sacrée
très, très importante.
- Mon coeur bat très fort,
car depuis hier, je perçois
avec pacacacacuité l'énormité
de ce que nous commettons.
- Le vol de ce kono bouleverse
Michel Leiris, dont les carnets
de route deviendront un livre
à son retour à Paris
- Juin 1933. Le butin
de la mission, 3600 objets,
a été élégamment mis en scène
par Georges Henri-Rivière.
- Ce documentaire soulève
l'enjeu des objets d'art
africain dérobés à ces peuples.
- La moindre des choses,
ça sd'd'd'd'en parler.
Et justement ce qui me choque,
moi, c'est que dans le musée du
quai Branly, comme dans d'autres
musées, d'ailleurs, en Europe,
e e e e raconte pas réellement
l'histoire de ces objets quand
on la connaît. Pourquoi ne pas
raconter le... donner l'extrait
de Michel Leiris sur u,,,,,
à côté de l'objet kono, exposé
au musée du quai Branly en
disant : "Voilà, il a été volé,
dans quelles conditions, etc."
- Comment regarder aujourd'hui
ces objets orphelins?
- Le réalisateur est favorable
à la restitution de ces objets,r
religieuse et culturelle.
- Ils viennent de là et ils sont
utiles là-bas, beaucoup plus que
chez nous. Le message c'est ça,
c'est : "Partageons avec les
pays d'où viennent ces objets
une réflexion. Pensons
à restituer, si c'est souhaité,
pensons à faire connaître
leurs conditions d'acquisition.
C'est ça, c'est un échange
et une parole ouveumumumumumumée
sur ces questions.
- Des questions qui nous
plongent dans la plaie toujours
béante de la colonisation.
Ici Catherine François,
Radio-Canada, Montréa